do you guys just feel like you're having
a pinch me kind of moment being in this
DC universe I mean it feels like it's
perhaps like a childhood dream maybe to
some to be in like a comic book film was
that the case for y'all
yeah this is my first big feature film
and for it to me like this ginormous
Harley Quinn DC movie is crazy I still
can't believe it it feels like one long
dream like someone needs to pinch me
away but you're an old soul you're like
a pro cuz like you've been doing this
forever
yeah what about you Margo being in this
DC Universe I'm just so happy that the
movies finally about to come out I feel
like it's been a pretty long word to get
here and at points I was like it's never
gonna happen I guys just can't get it up
over the line you know well it was a
pretty risky proposition when I first
pitched it you know four and a half
years ago I put the pitch together and I
was saying I think we should do a female
ensemble action film with an r-rating
and that sounded like an insane thing to
do and you know I I could totally
understand everyone's hesitation and
then movies like Deadpool started coming
out and proving that you can do an
r-rating in the comic book space and
have it be successful and I think it's
not even in the comic book world but I
feel like films in general and maybe
that's thanks to streaming services and
things like that but I feel like this is
such a positive response to something
new and fresh and different and people
are really hungry to see something they
haven't seen before particularly in this
day and age so I feel like all those
things helped kind of get this this film
up and running and now I'm just I'm just
stoked it's gonna be out in the world
are we ready love seeing that female
power on screen but also behind the
screen as well from producing to
directing and screenwriting so very cool
has to you for short now I got to talk
to you about a particular scene in
particular there was the sequence where
you were shooting diamonds are a girl's
best friend so that had to be especially
fun to shoot we've seen that scene you
know kind of play out in different
atmospheres before but were you
channeling more of like a Marilyn Monroe
or Madonna Material Girl bit both
because I think there's like a bit of
Holly and in both but I think it was
more that the theme obviously and the
diamond is such prevalent and MacGuffin
throughout the whole film right
but it was really interesting and
something that Kathy spoke about a
director spoke about a lot and her
initial pitches the what diamond
represents and what the idea of society
puts on it - you know as as far as women
are concerned and and this like
ownership such desire and she had this
incredible idea about diamonds in
general and we we knew that we really
wanted to play into that and that not
only gives you an iconic moment to kind
of replicate that Marilyn look on the
stairs it also meant that we all got to
do dance lessons and so it was it was
fun it was poignant thematically
appropriate yeah so good though it's
like which was more difficult the dance
scenes and the dance rehearsal or some
of the stunts you know what I mean the
training for that what did you make of
that scene I think a versus like I
should be in the dance scene we're like
do you want it yes and we were like
that's a great idea what did you love
most about your costumes favorite
elements they're my favorite question
was that Marilyn oh yeah because it was
you know a beautiful replica of the
iconic look yeah with trousers instead
of the skirt modernising it a bit
actually I actually love my casts I feel
like that's that's kind of her armor and
her shield and it's really a part of her
and I actually designed all of the stuff
on the cast like a bunch of bad words
and like blood and stuff but that was
that was super fun and I actually got to
keep it a great souvenir I liked at all
we had a great costume designers it's
amazing you know when you put on you did
a lot of times you're finding your
character through the through costume
fittings and this in particular all the
Wardrobe
I have to say I if I was gonna steal
anyone's clothes it would have been sad
as its closed there was so many outfits
where I was like I would wear that
Thanks so yeah some of it Travis we're
actually ladies yeah yeah ask what is
your hubby think of your whole Harlequin
transformation and get up hey know who I
mean I think he thought it looked really
cool yeah he really really liked the
costumes in this one the whole look I
never actually asked him which version
of Holly B prefers aesthetically because
there's three now I'll skin the next
time I choke and we'll have to catch up
on that yeah yeah so we see Harley go
through this transformation where she
cuts her hair cuz it's post-breakup so
it's kind of like that moment for her to
rid herself of the Joker from a physical
perspective you guys ever had a moment
where you've gone through a breakup and
you feel like oh I bet I do something
drastic like chop my hair and just have
some huge transformation there I haven't
done anything quite as yet dramatic is
as the stage as a breakup that Holly
goes through but I do have a wonderful
group of girlfriends back in Australia
we've been for instance we were like 4
years old and any time it dude breaks up
with a girl in the group all the girls
go in Aggies car one time I broke up
with a boyfriend and now alive day he
we're gonna go kick him and I was like
no door yeah oh my gosh you know award
season is wrapping up for you Margo and
unfortunately you had to miss out on the
Oscar luncheon and seeing that cast
photo did you have like major FOMO for
missing out I mean yes and no yes
because I did the last time I went to
that lunch and it was it is a really
really special event and I got to sit
next PTA so life goes right there but um
no it to be here with this film and with
these guys I I really am so so happy so
I wish I could duplicate myself and be
in many places at one time I'm just
happy to be here
[Music]